I will not tolerate this kind of
behavior in any agency but especially in
the IRS so the IRS has admitted to
sitting on applications for tax-exempt
status by tea party groups for political
reasons but regardless of how this
particular scandal shakes out in the
long run there's always going to be at
least three good reasons to be scared as
hell of the IRS have you received a
letter from us recently yeah I know that
can be scary John F Kennedy Lyndon
Johnson and Richard Nixon all sick the
IRS on enemies and dissenters and they
were just following in the footsteps of
Franklin Roosevelt whose son said his
father was quote the originator of the
concept of employing the IRS as a weapon
of political retribution have you
received a letter from us recently yeah
I know that can be scary the federal tax
code is longer than Atlas Shrugged
Ulysses and the Old Testament put
together it's so complicated that even
former IRS commissioners need help
preparing their returns have you
received a letter from us recently yeah
I know that can be scary starting next
year the IRS will be the cop controlling
the Affordable Care Act mandates with
the agency overseeing some 47 tax
provisions related to Obamacare you
won't just be reporting income anymore
you'll be explaining when where and how
you bought health care as well for
reason TV i'm nicholas lee have you
received a letter from us recently yeah
I know that can be scary but don't panic
and please don't ignore it